こんにちははじめ社長です今日は
お家事情の動画ですあの僕非常に
ややこしい生活の仕方知っておりまして
初めて肇社長の音の見る人そしていつも見
ている人にもちょっとわかりやすく肇社長
がどこで動画をどう思っているのか簡単に
説明させていただきます1分ください
どうぞ
肇社長の湯チューバーした魚事情
こんにちは僕はじめ8面は普段静岡に住ん
でいるよ静岡大学出身で市場化の居心地が
よくて富山出身だけどそのまま修行かね今
も活動をしているんだねはじめして頭が
住んでいる静岡類はもう6人感も住んで
いるんだ大家さんとも仲良しはじめ説教が
作った比べずという言うチューブ
チャンネルのメンバーもカップというした
上でいつもみんなで撮影しているんだね
その一方で初めは売れっ子に自分で言うの
もなんですけど初めは売れっ子で東京で
よくお仕事や繁栄をしていましたなぜなら
初めにな所属支部事務所大府も東京にある
からにだから初めはある東京にも応じを
つくりました作ってはねは肇社長は東京に
も大きを借りて静岡に帰れない日はこの
東京のなり木のようなお家でローがを振っ
ているんだだから初めは市領下で撮影 ok
東京でも100 a ができるなぜ静岡に
窓住んでいるかって簡単なりうさ
やりたい放題の6人かも守備と大家さんと
も仲良し近所の一つは意外と仲良し大本意
だしたり叫んだりアフ米雇用しても意外と
許されるだだから初めは今何し浄化に住ん
でいるんだねー
小川ちょっとオーバーしましたはい今のが
肇社長の動画撮影どこでしているの事情で
ございます何か最近も本当にそが救って
東京になが1週間いたりすることもあって
東京でもよく撮影するんですけども結局
静岡スは結局静岡ですもう大家さんも
優しい叫んでも大丈夫だしもっといろんな
派まあもう動画の幅の連嶺が違いすぎて
討議をた静岡だとちょっと僕は東京にあの
ある際二号艇みたいな東京の豪邸を借りて
動画を撮ってみても東京だったら今もう
こんなのときって外で動画とるなんて全然
降り出し北東京いるとき仕事以外でそっと
出ないんで名華も溶けないような場所だと
僕はしか活動できないなと思って意外と
動画撮る時外とかで暴れたりするんで林件
的な部分や環境的な部分を考えると僕は
静岡のこの家とか静岡で撮影する場所だけ
は絶対とっておきたいと思っていました
思っていましたが
今回
今回ですね私
決心しましたそしても動き出しております
6年割断この家
まあ隣の家もかけてるんで71号室2号室
って2疲れているんですけども今比べずが
使っている部屋も合わせると6年間ここら
へんに済ませていただいたんですけども
引越ししようと
思います思いますじゃありません思いまし
たヤー9ずうずうの決断と言いますかまあ
いろいろ理由があるんですけどもこれ誰に
言うのが一番緊張するかって大家さんなん
ですよ6年間本当にお世話になってもう
こんなさあ2の物件に僕みたいな人形
しまったら間違いなく苦情だらけになる
ような事を本当全部許してもらって本当に
心から感謝してるんですけどもその大家
さんにいうのがとても心苦しい通貨別に何
かこのいいが悪いってわけじゃないんです
よ自由がなんですけど本当に多い30の時
は緊張するんでちょっと今からとりあえず
親さんに引越ししますっていう報告今から
知っていきますが多いさ知らないです多分
悲しみかなわかんないけどなんで大家さん
での報告も含め皆さんへの説明にもなると
思いますのでぜひご覧くださいねtap
教頭のんなんですよ発生します
お久しぶりすすめです
売り切れ何度か調和ですね大家さんには
まだ言ってないんですけどとても大きな
発表と言いますか
結構したいです今ではないんですけどあの
この
親に貸していただいている
汚物に
15から始まると約6年ぐらいモハ
いただいてるんですけどもこの度
家を買うことにしましたん
おめでとう
ございますそうですよのおうちょう
借りると指もう
スタジオがあっていっ
50があってそうですねうまく分かれて
必要だとアウトですかうんそんな餌の母屋
さんからお借りしてるうちがもうほんと
広いじゃないですかそもそもの3階建てで
広いし動画を撮っても大家さんの許可が
あってからこその本当に大きなこれだっ
たり自由にほど痩せていっ
にひびかな導かないんだよ自由本論に6
年間やらせていただいたんですけども東京
に住み始めてからなんかやっぱり東京だと
思うん
大声を出せないし
今ご時世的に外も出れないを静岡た環境が
違いすぎてもっと静岡でトリル動画を
パワーアップしたいなと思いまして
ちょっとこれ以上を激しいことをしたり
壁を打つに至り金するにはもうちょっと
大家さんの元夫
食べたったなければいけないのかなとその
真剣のあの僕の部屋とか無いよ
まあもう会さんいつも笑顔でそう言っても
僕最初にでも遊びに来ていただきたいが
絶対親方と思ってるけど僕のペアってやつ
ちょっとあのうぎゃーっ
往路すごい生きていただいてよちょっと
きっこ氏のことはティ
本当屋さんには売ってさんと言わなきゃと
キュウリビズです6年6年ですさ動画せ
られたら対処に引っ越したのが6年前です
色々あったような
本当に色々ありますから7キロ痩せた事件
です7キロああああさんまたらやと
ストーカーが内に入ってきた事件も予算ね
あれカメラつけててよかったですねそうね
それを機にお家さんにあの監視カメラ蛆虫
かけていただいたり今までずっと賃貸でき
たんで打つを買う
んですよ賃貸で借り立月データのは本当
大家さんだった彼がです本当に
のちょっとこれからも来た追い出されてる
でしょで6年間を屋さんのおかげで改造
できてると思ってるよここ見つけた
ゾロ僕でうまいちょっと迷ったんですよ
ここ待ったしなんか駅前のターンとかも
あったんだけど地面についている方がもの
ルパンとかも含め4辺が建物だもんなここ
自分で言うのもなんだけど編んですけど
最高ですよ
本当に6年間がた小学生という下がっ2
ぐらいメジャーになってるんでも中学生に
なっちゃうそうですよね自分の家という僕
は次の家も動画はための良いだと思ってる
ぞ本屋さんの移ればできなかった壁を貫通
させるだけだっ
やってみたい
皆さん的にはやっぱり寂しいですかゾーラ
寂しい
だってフラット絶対会えないじゃんんです
かないやーなんかフラット会えない寂しさ
んってのはあるよね
呼べば会えるけどあー
民族と大谷さん
[音楽]
愛情大丈夫
持って行くならくらいじゃないですよ
鈴岡の
お父さんだと思ってたんで
鈴僕もそのつもりでなんかだなくなっ
はい水羊羹ガーディアとーございますっお
客さんにもなってする僕は静岡の地つだと
思ってるの親番かとそのつもりで接してき
ますね惹かれる
いや本当に寂しいし
いや俺も寂しいというかなんか一区切りと
いうか
2つというかね卒業ジっぽい気分で来年
から新しい中学に行く
自分社長に父がなるもネイルもなかった
いや全然も袋をあげようあっ歌ったほうが
よご覧いただきます幸運の袋1個監視
カメラつけてくださったりだとか
普通に何かあった時に連絡して下さり直感
ボロボロ含めて本当に6年間ありがとう
ございますこちら
[音楽]
よやめ一番の思い出はあればなきゃイヤせ
た時だあそこで
あの変な家お客さんと僕っていう関係が何
か食って次元が変わっていただけますねと
その家にも良されたじゃないって言ったん
だろうかそれですごい
相談したりさせていただいてて津波に次の
日較差年で
多分私ばかりされていないって言う
さんがございます3つだから握手をでき
ないんだろうということで2つ無言で飽き
てしまってもいい
ok ありません
[音楽]
ええええええ
wh
me
anidee
[音楽]